ciao a tutti ragazzi buon 2020 questo
qui diciamo è il primo video di questo
nuovo anno
vi auguro non è il primo video è il
secondo video di questo nuovo anno
infatti bravi che siete attenti per
quest'anno dove ha pensato di mettere un
pochino in ordine le idee questo canale
vorremmo che fosse perché si vede le
vecchie abitudini non cambiano mai in
forse arrivato il momento di fare un
pochino diciamo di di chiarezza su come
cambierà e come si evolverà questo
canale
state tranquilli la prima casa e vi dico
è che cucina buttata rimarrà sempre la
domenica martedì mi sono lasciato
convincere un sacco di commenti che mi
sono arrivati io non volevo io non
volevo aggiungere un altro video
l'ultima cosa che avrei voluto fare
raggiungere lavoro anche perchè siamo
pieni di roba da fare e provate mi sono
detto sti cavoli cerca di seguire anche
un pochino la pancia mi sono arrivati
commenti meravigliosi che mi hanno fatto
un pochino pensare ok tirar fuori questo
contenuto ossia un blog settimanale
riuscirà quindi il martedì e infine
arrivati il giovedì la giornata di oggi
fin da buttare tranquilli non se ne va
per renderlo un appuntamento pochino più
diluito perché sono dell'idea che il
troppo stroppia
anche perché sono dopo un po diventa
tutto quanto ripetitivo e alla fine
parliamo solo del merda e non merda
merda cioè merda fisica sto pensando a
una soluzione per rinnovare e format non
dico niente lancio la chiave è fatto
così te è una serratura quindi della cia
chiave non amo i canali che sono
unidirezionali soltanto i quali le
persone devono solamente assorbire
assorbire assorbire senza poter dire la
loro e vero che esistono i commenti ma
trovo che ad oggi si possa fare di più e
ci possa essere modi più efficaci nuovi
divertenti per ascoltare diciamo le
persone che ti seguono alla fine
più protagoniste forse potrebbero
tornare guglielmo tell forse potrebbero
uscire fuori nuove idee
questa è una di quelle che ci è venuta
vi ho chiesto quali sono i vostri buoni
propositi per il 2020 su instagram
adesso vorrei semplicemente commentarli
eleggerli insieme a voi niente più faq
boys allora non so che cosa tu in te che
cos'è che intende niente più persone con
le quali solamente fare sesso
grazie a gianmarco per marco storari a
parigi dipende
credo che il sesso non sono cosa per
forza da condannare
basta vuole la persona ford no io credo
più che altro che una cosa importante
sia tanto lo spirito qualcosa si
affrontano le cose la cole e la
cosciente la coscienza e la coscienza
con la quale si affrontano le esperienze
questo è cosa vuol dire che c'è una
grandissima differenza fra bere 2 litri
di vino ogni sera è perso un bicchierino
ogni tanto a cena in realtà nella
maggior parte delle cose non tutte
quante ovviamente non c'è niente di male
l'errore siamo noi finire in carcere che
vuole finire in carcere
in bocca al lupo scopare di più se va
bene fidanzarmi ma per questo devo
trovare il coraggio bisogna stare molto
attenti alla polvere effettivamente di
coraggio e vero però meno nella testa il
quadrato con del sentimento costruito
sull'ipotenusa del cazzo cioè va al
quadrato
no a me prego no più easy io sto
imparando una cosa 32 anni che vivere un
pochino di più la giornata con tutte
quante le intenzioni migliori per il
futuro per il domani perché è così che
riesce a fare un lungo tragitto passo
dopo passo poi se inciampi
amen io oggi per esempio mio cugino e
mio fratello qua e sono infelice
come poche persone al mondo essere
sempre più umida a umana devi dire
commossa dalla neve
te lo auguro ma è sempre quello che
voleva scovare di più farmi passare st
cotta che dura da quasi un anno mo basta
maison rotta ovviamente lui non
ricambiati capisco perché mi è successo
posso veramente dare quello che secondo
me è l'unico l'unico metodo ufficiale
per smette di pensare una persona trova
teme un altro team atto non capisce
impossibile non c'è no in un anno il
provato a guardarmi ayala guardati
ancora più attorno circa in essere più
umano ecco ok ma sai perché perché hanno
paura di vincere e quindi al momento in
cui tu sai di volere qualcosa che non
puoi avere parti già sconfitto almeno è
una certezza il maggio di quanto sarebbe
più terrorizzante pensare di potersi
meritare una cosa e quindi affrontarla
veramente io credo che sia una sorta di
a volte non sempre mcaleese min con
inconscio di autosabotaggio volere
quello che non si può avere sei sicuro
di non averlo almeno cosa sia una paura
di vincere e non paura di perdere lo
dico sempre scoprire cosa non funziona
nel modo giusto nel mio corpo e trovare
un modo per sistemarlo spero che non sia
un discorso medico ecco perché in quel
caso che auguro tutto il bene e la
fortuna
del del mondo se invece è una pattuglia
tua non c'è niente di male il tuo corpo
sa però purtroppo viviamo in una società
che secondo me e questo lo dico a me ne
frega un cazzo perché lo penso e devo
dire le cose che penso questo il mio
proposito del 2020 mettere cerca di
compiacere la gente e quindi
assomigliare sempre di meno me stesso
no preferisco essere uguale all'immagine
che ho di me al massimo sta sul cazzo a
qualcuno proviamo in una società che
secondo me promuove troppo in maniera
eccessiva il seashow che sei sì quello
che sei
e giustissimo ma allo stesso tempo
secondo me a volte alcune persone che
prendono troppo come una scusa e mi sono
fatto così e quindi magari si avvelenano
con la loro emotività che magari è
sbagliata come viene usata si avvelenano
col cibo e che trasformano il discorso
di essere curvi fa bene in io possa
attentare alla mia salute perché tanto
curvi e bello no quello è sbagliato
ragazze cioè un po come dire i gay sono
sensibili
se frasi fatte sul non è vero successo
dai test di cazzo partorire a luglio
beh se partorisci a gennaio dell'anno
prossimo se la balena il tempo di
gestazione della balenottera azzurra
quindi trovo anch'io eh si anche da un
pochino sì in sette mesi
auguri speriamo fare coming out in bocca
al lupo nessuno ti corre dietro sono i
tuoi tempi respira si è calato il
microfono è vero volermi bene liberarmi
di queste chiappe di stracchino e fare
movimento o in bocca al lupo ho quasi
perso il mio ragazzo per colpa mia
cercherò di essere meno autodistruttivo
io leggo tra le righe
sappilo in realtà poi deve anche pensare
una cosa che cercherà i sì di essere
meno auto distruttivo per quello che
distrugge anche un'altra persona
ok quindi quando si sta in coppia
azioni che ricadono su di noi ricadono
sull'altro e viceversa
però occhio perché a volte è più
importante il male che sia dagli altri e
anche solo quello dovrebbe essere un
incentivo per rimanere insieme una
persona o anche no guarire dalla bulimia
aumentare la mia autostima provare a
realizzare i miei sogni o innanzitutto
grazie per questo commento non dirò mai
che sei il tuo nome tavolo veramente di
cuore di riuscire a farcela
non è semplice se io non posso nemmeno
immaginare come si possa stare nei miei
panni
ci si guarisce conosco un sacco di
persone che sono riuscite a uscire da un
problema così personale anche così
intimo che a volte li fa sentire forse
immagino fragile invisibile sbagliata ti
auguro veramente riuscire a trovare
quell'equilibrio che ti possa permettere
di accettarti di non dover ricorrere a
nessun tipo di mezzuccio per aggiustarsi
che non c'è niente che tu debba
aggiustare se non il modo in cui ti
guardi allo specchio impegnarmi
all'università andare sotto gli 87 kg
per cambiare categoria delle gare ho
anch'io
anch'io vorrei andare sotto i 120 perché
il suo essere difficile
vivo da sepolta in casa nel vero senso
della parola su una limited a soli
uscirne non è semplice immagino immagino
allo stesso tempo ma solo gente
veramente una cosa da magia di come se
fosse tutto un fratello maggiore
questa non è una cosa devi fare infatti
da sola questa mente una cosa per cui ci
sono persone che studiano non poi magari
chiederà genitori un amico qualcuno o
anche magari cercare online un bravo
psicoterapeuta qualcuno che veramente di
possa dare una moda e capire da dove
venga questa questa chiusura ha colpisto
persone che grazie alla terapia per cui
non bisogna essere matti per andare in
terapia perché veramente una concezione
sbagliata a grazie alla terapia sono
riuscita veramente a fiorire e dio
benedica alle persone che studiano per
dare una mano alla mente a volte bisogno
veramente di aggiustare di stoccare non
solo i pelle piccole crepe nel muro ma
anche le piccole crepe che abbiamo
anima così da dimenticare una persona un
tesoro non la dimenticherà mai
l'unico modo per dimenticarla a
ricordarne una nuova faccio una
citazione pochino nerd se tu perdi torni
sempre al salvataggio che ha fatto prima
ok tu hai bisogno di trovare un nuovo
posto dove salvare il videogioco tommaso
check point torni sempre a un mostro
importante invece deve andare avanti ma
pensare alla nuova al nuovo mostro che
può essere positivo è naturalmente tutto
un'allegoria merde merde diversi devi
trovare uno che preme il tuo triangolo
si ferocemente altro cerchio ho capito
solamente una cosa non ho capito
diventare ricca e magra stando sul
divano a mangiare
dovrai cagare un botto allora in quel
caso è trasformare in oro 2 feci e
chiudiamo con ridere di più e per questo
ci sono io scherzi a parte ragazzi sono
arrivati alla fine di questo video mi
piacerebbe fare delle chiacchiere e più
intime con voi a me piace molto
rispondere su instagram alle domande
cerco di non farlo troppe volte ma non
so se mi diverto da morire
fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuto fatemi
sapere soprattutto quali sono i vostri
buoni propositi del 2020 che cosa
pensate dei consigli che magari sono
stati dati a questi ragazzi che cosa
pensate di quello che hanno detto che ce
li vedete non mi ci vedete
magari ho detto qualcosa sulla quale
siete d'accordo magari ha detto qualcosa
sulla quale siete in disaccordo che
volete completare la pole e volete
aggiungere un paio di puntini sulle i
fatemelo sapere sono sempre aperto al
confronto non ho paura di una
conversazione costruttiva come sempre
iscrivetevi a questo canale mettete un
pollice in su per il anche perché dopo
tutto quello che mi sono mangiato di
scudi anche bloccare in qualche modo
detto questo ci vediamo questa domenica
con il primo episodio di cucina buttata
del 2020 ciao